[Musique]
fini devant mon génie mais moi j'ai ni
de manger ni devant les gens jettent à
terre je mange les poésies légaux les
japonais des sciences imaginez vous dans
un musée vous voulez vous venez de
perdre votre chapeau et votre manteau
dans les vestiaires où vous inviter à
observer les oeuvres d'art et vous avez
marre at car vous avez votre objet
symbolique de votre liberté entre vos
mains
et personnellement mon moi mais pour
tout ça peut être d'autres choses et
d'autres objets et tout à coup une
personne sort bien elle s'apprête à
réduire votre liberté car ils voient
commandes expérience et en minimes et
par oui alors on se demande pourquoi
pourquoi qui s'approche vers nous et à
notre surprise ils ont retiré retirer un
élément de nous qui va nous contrôler
une rare un peu been érable alors
contrôler cette maladie
eh bien je me demande pourquoi lego lego
de tout genre de tueur
tu veux créer de l'anxiété de la
sécurité au sein de cette société
le racisme neutre notre système
capitalisme ou corrompus le lait les
gens qui meurent de violence eh bien
pourquoi encore le rappeler ces
problèmes on a trouvé une solution est
en fait tu veux pas trouver comment
arrêter le racisme et tout cela parce
qu'il sait déjà la racine ses lego lego
barbie douce et or de reprendre à
l'éliminer pour devenir une commune
maxi est forte alors on a commencé comme
jour à la fois en charge le monde en
faisant une différence pour pouvoir nous
respecter entre nous mettre nous mêmes
et respectent nos valeurs
ciao à tous leurs problèmes
on voit toujours tout comme superman t
on dirait une hiérarchie sociale
en fait on retrouve comme une autorité
quand il aura nous enfants de respecter
l'autorité mais est ce vraiment bien son
voisin d'une supériorité mais plutôt de
respecter la personne à côté de nous à 6
cellules
c'est le même problème à l'école à
l'école on valorise beaucoup
l'individualité on se confondent
toujours l on respecte toujours les
personnes qui sont devant nous mais
qu'il n'a rien on doit écouter les
sensibilités il s'en est étonné qu'on
peut changer aujourd'hui changé et on
veut respecter et le génie de combat les
enfants alors c'est pour cela j'aimerais
inviter mes amis qui va également nous
expliquer pourquoi pascal jenny est
important car l'éducation est composé d
expérience bonjour je m'appelle sa
charge
j'aimerais en fait les pieds sauf pistes
proposées comme les hives part belle aux
électeurs que ce que je peux vous
raconter c'est qu'une fois j'étais avant
l'été avec les grands du talent et au
musée et evans a toujours se battre
parce que c'est assez symbolique au
lycée c'est comme comme quelqu'un dont
pourrait avoir un crime dans sa main
ça faisait quelque chose solide et on
n'a même pas le temps de rentrer dans la
musique que tout de suite à cause comme
un ballon pour être utilisé pour une
lancée ou qui pourrait casser un objet
tout de suite on juge on attaque et
vendent tout de suite les gars sont
revenus ils ont réduit notre cadeau et
un ballon haut il préférait casser des
objets mais pourquoi vous un enfant
c'est par là s'est pas gêné c'est pas
quelque chose d'instable c'est pas de
bon qui pourrait déclencher à tout
moment et moi je trouve ça bizarre parce
que même moi à l'école comme des voix
quand j'avais dû trouve l'avant genre je
demandais aux demandes et aux études
pourquoi est-ce que responsable des
conséquences on me répondait jamais on
sait juste au dessus tu n'y es tu va en
subir les conséquences
ils sont toujours en train de faire sa
rentrée de faire baisser toujours prête
à abaisser le listing l'isoloir gens
crient de dandong leur génie je vais
vous dire en fait saviez-vous que les
scientifiques ont fait une recherche et
que les hommes en avant l'école on sent
beaucoup plus créative et ont beaucoup
plus d'imagination
après l'école c'est vous qui les aident
les adultes sont du coup moins
imaginatifs sa mesure que l'école
comment c'est fait ça enlève ce génie
chez endroit que pas de mon fait
comprendre que les foisonnements les
enfants de comprendre puis cissé génique
des voix qui pourrait justement notre
soeur était à l'université je vous dis
un truc vais voir mourir mais repenser
répond 6 10 de voix
imaginez si des enfants pourrait être
dirigée par exemple
c'est que ça vous à vous paraître
bizarre mais imaginez comment des fois
quand même un enfant comprend pas
pourquoi ils étaient punis
l'adulte est valable de se mettre dans
sa peau et bizarrement c'est vrai on
pourrait dès cette chance je vais
pouvoir imaginer un enfant un enfant qui
tu es riche qui pourrait comprendre les
élèves qui presque dans la brousse
plaisir à bon si ce n'est plus à moi
aussi j'étais comme ça imaginez une
société comme ça je me c'est un ami qui
est des revenus là dessus puisque
ricardo mais c'est sacha
[Musique]
nous croyons que de montrer des
environnements favorables à la
préservation du génie nos enfants
pourquoi le québec là une certaine
particularité une des provinces et prier
sans du canada démographie particulière
il fait en sorte que non seulement nous
devons ouvrir nos frontières
si vous couvrir nos perspectives parce
qu'on ne me le permettent
en tant que société de perdre le
potentiel créatif et imaginatif d'un
seul jeune
nous faisons face à des vieux problème
l'autre dimension du territoire
québécois une particulière et lorsque
bout du monde occupé sial les rues de
montréal
ce qu'on a fait dans le cadre d'un
projet pilote à la fête pendant cinq ans
en occupant différents espaces publics
on se rencontre j'ai fait qu'il ya
certaines essences dans dans l'absence
de deux parcs naturels dans l'occupation
des espaces une sécurité des voies qui
approchent différents citoyens avec
différences d'approché et cela nuit à
l'expérience l'expérience qu'on peut
considérer comme étant dans l'optique de
citoyenneté culturelle
c'est pour ça que si on écoute nos
enfants plus tôt comme le dit le
chercheur john dowland
comme l'a si bien résumé de sacha qui
dit qu' environ cinq ans les jeunes
réussissent des tests qui ne peuvent
réussir quand ils sont adultes à cause
d'un potentiel créatif
si on crée des oeuvres non favorable à
l'entretien du génie chez nos jeunes
nous ferons face à des conflits qui
préviendront une certaine forme de
violence que nous vivons dans nos
sociétés
car ce que les spécialistes des crises
urbaine nous dit chabrol chemin il dit
pour éviter la violence
il faut cesser d'éviter les conflits et
les conflits qu'on parle de conflits
emballé tout simplement des idées qui se
heurte le fait que les ventes par
exemple veut aller dans un musée ou
montée le mans baroeul tout le monde cet
hiver ou occuper des espaces publics
avec un ballon de football dans la main
droite sans nécessairement le nom c'est
parce qu'il sait il a une vision à long
terme ils se voient dans la nfl le fait
que ça chacun il occupe un espace public
il a besoin
il est certaine énergie qui doit
sillonner l'espace pour être confortable
avec ce dernier il faut se questionner
sur nos hypothèses et nos preuves et 130
sociétés
lorsqu'on est ce qu'on crée vraiment des
villes qui sont favorables à la présence
de nos jeunes à la présence de nos aînés
à la préservation de leur expérience
c'est tous ces de ces questions que nous
nous posons en tant que collectif
donc sans plus tarder j'aimerais
présenter mes veines qui a sa propre
théorie qui manifestent avec son corps
et des espaces publics fait du prime au
mérite
[Applaudissements]
pour pression qu'on se sent en place on
bosse on peut sûrement plus on n'entend
pas y apprend plus en compression ou
dublin refusé de la table rase sont
dénoncés pour tourner la page
jamais colonisé lancer des dommages
ténèbres il a ajouté que les sondages
s'est passé corps noir est souvent gage
médicamenté de voir l'écran entre les
deux groupes ce qui est gênant je peux
m'arrêter à doter notre ligue
comme tu le sais que ce monde est pourri
et de voir la caméra sourit alors qu on
paie notre côté fragile et complice n'a
jamais ça peut être docile quoi comme un
appel d'offres présentées moyens pour
moi je veux des objets des projets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]